do you wanna explain what kg is quickly
servi yes so it's it's it's it's a
gambling what it's a gambling story so
this guy racks up this massive massive
debt I forgot what why he'd racked up
this massive debts icon why did I for
some reason so so basically he gets an
offer from this like mysterious company
that can that can clear his debt that
just says you need to go on the ship and
you're gonna play a bunch of games and
you if you win these games then we will
clear your debts or you can go into even
greater debts yeah and the basic premise
is just Kaiji on the ship or just like
after after the ship arcs over it's just
him going through a bunch of different
gambling games and just trying to clear
his debts and and he's not Opie so
that's like the best part yes genuinely
he loses a lot very much as he wears and
it's great because you generally don't
know if he's gonna lose a winner yeah
it's a very quotable it's really a lot
of them watch it I think mainly because
for some reason it was only published in
480p really you was only publishing an
EP yeah it came out in 2007 as well it
was only 480p and I remember like when I
was watching it I'm like where's what's
this like so just know that when you
watch it it's gonna be like that but
it's definitely worth your time I don't
know I thought the reason why people
didn't watch car shows because of the
art style I think is that and I think um
I think there's a ton of reasons why
because like it's got like zero female
characters in there I think yeah I got
remember a single two got a lot of ugly
bastards that's cozy right imagine
imagine an NCR plot but instead of sex
it's just watching a guy it's just
gambling
it's just enter your gambling that's
just crazy okay but it's [ __ ] great
so good I'm going from watching Kaiji to
I don't know how you plan to catch a
guru okay it was like how can i watch
this [ __ ] when this gambling is so fake
oh yeah yeah it's all just [ __ ]
gambling to serve the plots I was in Chi
Chi it felt like real gamble cocky-doody
was just like this through if they were
like okay how do we make these hot girls
orgasm yeah gambling let's just throw it
like the main character always wins
unless it doesn't really matter then she
doesn't win and
it's like haha you didn't explain it's
like yeah but it didn't matter like yeah
exactly it's like the like there was a
one dumb moment that's the part I've
dropped the series when the girl with
the gun playing Russian roulette and
it's like it's obvious no one is going
to die in this situation don't pretend
like someone is going to die because I'm
not stupid
yeah and then I couldn't watch it
further cuz this is just dumb whereas if
that wasn't IG well it's like someone's
gonna die yeah which is great because
but then it wasn't sure maybe both of
them could die we don't hear that's the
best part about Chi Chi is that like you
just genuinely don't know now the middle
part of Chi Chi is the narrator's voice
oh yeah yeah why is that why is that
just that narrator in like every [ __ ]
show of that epoch I lost I already see
it's an anime you know you think you
know what's you this Netflix show this
narrator comes out you know every need
what's the follow-up series the spin-off
one with the middle management whatever
tonegawa it's it's quite funny it's if
you go in expecting kaity you're gonna
be very disappointed yeah if you want if
you want Kaji then you it's better if
you read like the or I don't know the
author's name but like read some of his
other works
akagi's really good takagi I've really
liked a car key was a car keys basically
mahjong Kaiji yeah I'm like here's the
thing I had no [ __ ] interest in in
mahjong I was watching the show I had no
[ __ ] rules of the I had no [ __ ]
clue of the rules mahjong either yeah
when you get drawn in right after I
finished I'll call girls like me yeah
the exact same thing I don't know which
show was use little girls competing in
Miss Hong tournaments I don't know which
I think it was Mac might've just been
called mahjong no I don't know what it
was I remember I was trying my god damn
past alone mahjong and I was like I know
I mean like you know mas comes in like a
lion made me really invested in shogi I
was like yeah I know what the [ __ ] shogi
is but then after I watch March comes in
like I want to learn show you I mean
show uses Japanese chess er yeah I know
yeah it'll be good at that I don't even
know how to play chess and yet I was
like sure you look fun